hey guys it's justine i'm here with ro
today hey how are you doing oh man i
mean what happened i've been doing
during all this coved well i'm excited
that we're back we just filmed a kitchen
gadgets episode on her channel so go
check it out today you know that i love
tech oh i know you love tech well i've
got a little something i got some like
old school tech well actually it's not
well i don't want to tell you why i
already told you it's old school so i
completely ruined surprise what is this
classic
stuff do you know
what this is
okay well i'm seeing that it's it's a
charger yep and of course we've got a
little apple on here so this is an apple
a charger do you know um do you know
what kind of charger that is
it's okay if you don't no it's fine well
it's real thick it's real thick she's
thick it's old got a thick plug
and
she's
also got this little thing on the back i
don't know what this is so
what's this little uh symbol that this
is a it's a fire wire
yeah a long time ago do you remember
i had a separate firewire that i would
use for with my camera to my
laptop yup back in the day and it was
like bright and i was like firewire yeah
firewire such a good name too we have
this yeah a firewire charger okay
that charges
what are justine what have you brought
over
what what is this so inside of this
apple polishing cloth did you know that
apple sells a polishing cloth for 19. i
can't believe you have one i mean that's
just fancy i mean you you have a apple
polishing cloth that's like you feel
like you can believe it though i do
i mean because it's you you got all the
tech stuff you know that's like when you
have sunglasses that are designer and
then you have like the designer polisher
for your lens you're like oh let me just
get my gucci
polishing claws yeah my little polishing
claw same thing same thing so there's
something what is it what is there
something do you want to like do you
want to reveal okay go ahead okay oh my
gosh yes uh me
just do a little like okay okay little
meal i'll just just like it would just
uh just un unfold yes
okay here we go everybody
[Music]
it's an it's an ipod no the original
ipod from these are
shiny these are so huge they weren't
this big
well were they yeah like this is what
what started it all does this still work
oh this is a relic you give it a press
it's 20 years this is a 20 this thing is
20.
wow i can't believe i've lived through
this this is 20 years old so this is
actually the 10 gigabyte version there
was definitely a smaller one than that
this isn't my original one i did buy
this on ebay a few years ago like check
out like this ipod font i can't even
believe they still have these like well
i'm shocked that you could even find one
online just because it's so old this is
so old justine applause museum i mean
i'm scared indiana jones is just gonna
shoot out from my kitchen and come steal
this okay well try to get this relic and
like put it in like some like tech
museum i'm gonna be on the lookout then
yeah we'll give it a little button press
let's see if it works i'm honored i'm
gonna okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
just the middle yep
it's working shut up
check it out
oh the screen is oh
oh and i still remember how to use it oh
so satisfying i know oh my gosh listen
listen listen listen listen this
the click
oh my god it's such a good sound
i love that click as i was driving over
here i was thinking wow oh yeah i have a
pair of air pods
it's not gonna work it's not gonna work
with airpods i don't this is not
bluetooth compatible what can you even
does it have the
look at the music so this has somebody
else's music on it because this is not
my ipod they didn't even clear it they
you got their music yes you got their
playlist yes this is a big deal we're
going to learn a lot about them look at
that screen is working
wow
so we've got the music here this is
history playlist artist album songs you
can put audio books on these yeah i
don't remember that i don't know there's
extras there's a game
okay i don't even i do vaguely remember
this oh it's kind of that pongy one yeah
where the the sliders at the bottom and
the ball goes and you and you move your
little slider i remember playing this in
like 2002 and thinking that like this
was
which it really was i mean this thing
was absolutely game changing isn't it
crazy the kind of games we can play on
our phones now from what we used to be
able to do yeah i was wondering if the
person who had this last had their
calendar synced up to this oh my gosh
this is synced up to january
2002 february oh my gosh we can see all
their plans hot date nights oh
all of the plans okay let's see what
kind of music they have oh my gosh we've
got their calendar we've got their
playlists i feel like we're best friends
abba okay
classic some adele great taste atlantis
more set oh my gosh alicia isn't that
ironic
we got buffy the vampire slayer slash
coldplay david okay did i look i feel
like this might actually be my playlist
lenny kravitz this is a good weird mix
i'm just really digging this is very
good you too you know what back in the
day i thought that i had the original
one but now i'm realizing looking at
this that i didn't get this right when
it came out i never owned the original i
had the ones that were they were a
little bit
thinner and they came in colors because
i had a nano that's what i had is
because i had a pink one and i thought
that was the first one no no i'm i'm
even behind even 20 years ago i was
behind the times
but like this is so cool like check out
like these edges like it's just like
it's such an awesome what's the top it's
got like a thick plexiglass on top you
know that kind that like you know it
lightly scratches but never like too
much it's actually pretty industrial
yeah you could really get in there we
got our headphone jack and we have this
little hold switch so if you don't want
to like hit any of the buttons you can
keep the song playing
firewire
i know isn't it sweet oh my gosh like
when a new jam came out and i just
wanted to listen to it on repeat you
just click that hold button on you just
yeah feeling it all day like yeah really
getting into your music but like let's
just look at that in comparison to like
what the iphone looks like right now
like you want the back look at that
the future and look at these ports i
mean look at your side parts and then
look at these fun fact hmm teach me the
facts justine what's the fun fact i may
have been like you know signing up to
myspace around then
and
i was like okay justine is taken so
whatever i'm just gonna throw an eye in
front of it
so here we are i still just can't
believe that this actually works like
after all these years like it's holding
a battery charge like i was charging it
over there and like it still is good i
feel like this is a miracle you guys
this this gadget is 20 years old it
still works it's still holding a charge
you know what i kind of miss this is
making me miss tech stuff this makes me
want to get my old nokia phone back and
use it for a week okay if i would really
love it so this all makes sense now
because i was wondering about like okay
so it was released october 23rd
2001.
oh okay
oh so but i think that i got i graduated
but i think i didn't obviously get it
when it first came out so
getting it around 2002 would make sense
dang this came out when i was a
sophomore in high school
i'm a few years older than you so i
think so yeah
i thought we were using it how old am i
i don't really i've been telling people
that i'm 38. and jenna goes you no
you're not okay so this is one part yeah
okay
so um kids you're just witnessing this
one
um i think we're both senile yeah and um
the ipod is still working which is
pretty pretty exciting i am shocked that
after 20 years still holding a charge
still working i think that speaks a lot
to the quality and longevity of these
items like that is really impressive i
have some phones by a manufacturer that
i won't name that i have they're only a
few years old
like the battery has like just engorged
and it's like leaking out battery acid
and this has lasted for like over 21
years 21 years later yeah wait 2 000 uh
2001. 21. oh she can drink now she's
legal drinking age we can make her a
margarita a spicy one because she
deserves it october
is would be the 21st birthday so we'll
bring it back out celebrate have a
little birthday
oh my gosh well thank you so much for
joining me in this vintage tech episode
this is
this is great i have to bring out some
more of it to check and see what i can
find for for our next video gosh yes
it'll be great well thank you guys so
much for watching make sure you go check
out ro's channel she is the best we have
been making so many videos over the past
couple of years i mean i have a whole
playlist of everything if you want to go
real wild
so yeah make sure you subscribe hit the
bell do all the things leave us some
comments and let us know if there's any
piece of tech you would like us to check
out next and we will see the next video
bye bye
[Music]
you